Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ça va ?
Est-ce que j’ai -
Ai-je pris suffisamment de temps
pour venir sur le tapis ?
Non, parce que je n’ai pas l’habitude
des conférences TED.
C’est ma 1e fois,
je n’ai pas encore les codes.
Et j’ai remarqué
qu’entre chaque intervenant,
souvent, il y a un petit temps.
Comment dire ?
Pas chiant, mais c’est quand même
difficile de le dire avec un autre mot.
Je ne sais pas si c’est une règle
qu’il faut respecter
ou si on peut prendre un peu de liberté.
Enfin bon, en tout cas, voilà,
je suis là, je suis sur le tapis
et je suis très heureux
d’être devant vous ce soir.
Je m’appelle Ben.
Évidemment, c’est un diminutif.
En réalité, je m’appelle Cédric.
Oui, Ben, c’est le diminutif
de mon nom de famille.
Je m’appelle Cédric Ben Abdallah.
Je pense que personne d’autre que moi
ne s’appelle Cédric Ben Abdallah.
Je pense que je suis la personne
qui a le moins d’homonymes sur Terre
et j’en suis ravi.
Donc, moi, je suis humoriste,
même si j’ai la chance
de ne pas en avoir l’air.
Je fais de l’humour
de manière professionnelle
et je fais également de la philosophie,
mais en amateur.
C’est exactement l’inverse
de ce que fait Frédéric Lenoir
qui lui fait de la philosophie
de manière très professionnelle,
mais qui, si je peux me permettre,
côté humour,
est encore un petit peu - sans animosité -
il y a encore un petit peu
d’amateurisme, je dirais.
C’est vrai que moi,
ce soir, si on m’a sollicité,
c’est beaucoup plus pour mes qualités
d’humoriste que pour celles de philosophe.
Même si à titre personnel, j'aurais adoré
faire de la philosophie avec vous.
Mais les organisateurs étaient
un petit peu fermés à cette idée.
Ils ont dit : « On aimerait que tu restes
concentré sur faire rire et c’est tout. »
J’ai dit : «Aucun problème,
c’est normal, c’est mon métier.
Je peux aussi faire de la philosophie,
ça ne me dérange absolument pas.»
Là, ils m’ont fait comprendre qu’eux,
en revanche, ça les dérangeait,
et de rester focus sur l’humour.
Je leur ai dit que
si c’est une histoire d’argent,
je ne demande pas
de budget supplémentaire.
Ils m’ont dit que ce n’est pas l’argent
car toute façon il n’y a pas de budget
du tout, ni pour ça, ni pour le reste.
Enfin, je ne sais pas.
Je les ai sentis un petit peu fermés
à l’idée de me voir aller
un petit peu au-delà de l’humour
et de m’aventurer sur les terres
de la philosophie.
Alors, tant pis s’il y a des gens
en attente d’un discours philosophique.
Je suis désolé, mais il ne va
vraiment pas y en avoir du tout.
Alors en revanche,
on m’a dit : « Attention, TEDx,
il faut quand même un humour d’un certain
standing, il faut que ça soit savoureux. »
Et ça tombe bien puisque j’ai un univers
qui est à la fois, je dirais, premium
et cucul la praline,
c’est-à-dire assez haut de gamme,
mais avec un petit goût de noisette.
Après, attention,
pas trop d’espoir non plus,
parce que je ne suis pas l’humoriste
le plus drôle de France.
Il y a des gens plus drôles
que moi en France.
Si on prend des gens comme...
je ne sais pas,
je n’ai pas de nom qui me vienne comme ça.
Enfin, ça doit être possible d’en trouver.
Plusieurs noms me viennent en tête
d’humoristes que je trouve
moins drôles que moi, en revanche.
J’ai fait une petite liste que vous pouvez
télécharger sur mon site Internet.
Il y a aussi un trombinoscope
pour ceux que ça intéresse.
En tout cas, je suis vraiment ravi
d'être devant vous ce soir.
C’est mon premier TEDx.
Quand j’ai reçu le brief de la soirée -
le brief, c’est un document PDF
sur lequel il y a écrit en gros :
« TEDxChantilly ».
Je me suis dit : «Allez, go !
On rassemble ses idées,
on agite ses petits neurones
et on écrit un texte sur la chantilly.
Pas évident comme sujet,
mais bon, tu n’es pas
plus bête qu’un autre.
En te retroussant les manches,
tu vas y arriver. »
Je travaillais à France Inter
et faire une chronique humoristique
à 7 h du matin en face de Nadine Morano,
ce n’est pas de la tarte non plus.
D’autant plus que, petite parenthèse
dans mon souvenir,
à la radio, ils sont très
à cheval sur les horaires.
Quand ils vous disent 7 h, c’est 7 h.
Si tu as le malheur d’arriver
à 8 h et demie : « Ragnagna...
L'émission est terminée.
Il faut apprendre à mettre un réveil. »
Ils ont une conception des horaires
qui est très allemande.
Or moi j’ai une approche sur les horaires
qui est un peu plus méditerranéenne,
voire moyen-orientale.
Si on me donne rendez-vous lundi 8 h,
je peux arriver le mardi après-midi.
Quelqu’un est venu me voir,
et m’a dit : «T’as pas compris.
En fait, le thème ce n’est pas Chantilly,
c’est Résiliences.
Et l’événement a lieu à Chantilly.»
J’ai dit : «Ben oui, merci,
j’avais compris, c’était une blague.
Je vous rappelle que c’est pour ça
que vous m’avez embauché.
Enfin embauché, que vous m’avez
demandé de venir.
Je ne suis pas idiot au point de
penser que le thème d’un TEDx,
ça peut être Chantilly.
Puis entre nous, quand j’ai cherché
le château de Résiliences dans mon GPS,
j’ai bien vu qu’il y avait un problème. »
Comme le thème de la soirée,
c’est Résiliences -
il n’y a plus rien derrière -
Résiliences avec un S.
Il y a eu plusieurs, voilà, plusieurs...
La résilience dans différents domaines.
J’ai voulu moi aussi trouver
un titre à mon intervention.
Je ne vous cache pas que j'ai eu un peu
de mal et finalement je me suis décidé
pour « Résilience et Tartiflette ».
C’est compliqué de trouver un titre,
on est toujours un peu contraint
de faire du marketing
au risque de négliger
la nuance du message.
Mais Résilience et Tartiflette,
c’est pas mal,
car ça donne des informations claires
sur les deux extrémités de l’intervention,
suffisamment éloignées l’une de l’autre
pour que je puisse mettre
tout et n’importe quoi à l’intérieur.
Et puis, c’est aussi un peu casse-gueule
de faire de l’humour sur la résilience.
Et je me dis : «Comme ça, si je perds des
gens avec des blagues sur la résilience,
je peux les rattraper avec
celles sur la tartiflette.»
L’autre avantage aussi d’accoler le nom de
cette recette à la thématique de ce soir,
c’est que « tartiflette »,
tout de suite, on a une image
et on a même l’odeur qui peut être
plus ou moins agréable,
selon qu’on adore le fromage ou qu’on a
un collègue qui sent un peu fort.
À France Inter,
des collègues qui sentent un peu fort...
Enfin bon, bref.
Et c’est vrai que résilience,
on a plus de mal à avoir une image.
Résilience, La seule image qui vient,
c’est un vieux monsieur
qui n’a plus beaucoup de cheveux,
probablement psychanalyste,
qui dit des trucs intéressants,
mais la seule chose qu’on comprend,
c’est qu’on va en avoir pour 200 balles !
Ouais, donc c’est pour ça
que j’ai intitulé ça...
Puis, je me suis dit aussi
que la résilience,
quelque part, c’est un peu
comme la tartiflette :
pour que ça fonctionne,
il faut avoir les bons ingrédients.
Et si vous voulez avoir
une bonne résilience,
l’ingrédient indispensable,
c’est le traumatisme.
Vous ne pouvez pas avoir de résilience
si vous n’avez pas de traumatisme.
Ne négligez pas la qualité du traumatisme.
Si vous voulez avoir de la...
J’ai presque envie de dire :
investissez dans un traumatisme
de qualité,
dans quelque chose de costaud, de solide,
parce que la vie est injuste.
Vous avez des gens
qui ne seront jamais traumatisés
et ils en souffrent, ils en souffrent.
Bien sûr, quand vous voyez des gens
à la télé qui disent :
«Je pense que nous sommes
en train de vivre la fin de l’abondance»,
on se dit qu’il n’a pas dû souvent
manger aux Restos du Cœur.
Je suis certes un peu privilégié
dans ce domaine-là
car je suis je suis d’origine algérienne,
or la France a offert à l’Algérie
une formidable opportunité
en matière de résilience,
en lui faisant cadeau d’un traumatisme
de très très grande qualité.
C’est vrai qu’il y a des gens qui sont,
je ne dirais pas jaloux,
mais qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
en matière de traumatisme,
qui vous disent :
«Moi aussi j’ai souffert,
j’ai eu des hémorroïdes l’an dernier.»
OK, je ne nie pas la douleur
que ça peut causer,
mais on voit bien que ça ne pourra pas
faire une conférence TED,
j’ai envie de dire, même à Chantilly.
Oh et puis flûte, écoutez,
j’ai quand même envie
de faire un petit peu
de philosophie pour conclure,
au risque de me froisser
avec les organisateurs.
Parce que c'est vrai que la résilience,
c'est un mot qui est très à la mode,
on l’entend beaucoup, c’est très chic,
c’est présenté comme une qualité.
Mais permettez-moi d’avoir
un doute là-dessus.
Parce qu’en théorie, il s’agit d’arriver
à dépasser ses traumatismes
et de continuer à faire preuve
d’enthousiasme pour envisager l’avenir.
C’est sûr, quand on le dit ainsi,
oui, c’est formidable.
Mais concrètement, concrètement,
imaginez quelqu’un qui se dirait :
«C’est vrai, toute ma famille est décédée
dans un accident d’avion
la semaine dernière,
mais ce week-end,
je vais à l’Aquaboulevard.»
Est-ce que ce n’est pas
juste un gros débile ?
On peut se poser la question, hein ?
Après, je vous avais prévenu,
la philosophie, je la pratique
en amateur uniquement.
Voilà.
Mais pour finir, je dirais que,
qu’on vit dans un monde
un peu étrange aujourd’hui,
mais qu’il faut quand même
rester optimiste
parce que je pense, fondamentalement,
que les choses vont s’arranger,
tout simplement parce
qu’on a survécu au 20ᵉ siècle.
Parce qu’il y a eu des tarés
dans l’histoire de l’humanité,
mais au 20ᵉ siècle,
il y avait une belle équipe.
D’accord, ce n’est pas terminé,
il y a encore des mecs qui s’entraînent,
mais, je suis sûr que ça va s’arranger.
Il suffirait que, voilà,
il faudrait que Vladimir se réveille
un matin, qu’il arrive au G20 :
«Putain les gars, je viens de lire
les 4 accords toltèques,
ça m’a complètement retourné.
Du coup, je laisse tomber l'Ukraine.
On va racheter un hameau
en Dordogne avec ma femme,
on va faire de la permaculture,
de l’agroforesterie.
J’ai bien retenu la leçon avec les arbres,
on va planter des petits noisetiers
entre les deux chênes, et tout.
(Accent russe) J’ai vu tuto sur YouTube
pour fabriquer déodorant soi-même.»
Mais il ne faut pas rêver.
Il ne perdra jamais son accent
d’un seul coup,
il y aura des étapes,
mais ça va bien se passer.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)